[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
mon thème c'est est-ce que nous sommes
rentrés dans la quatrième révolution de
l'humanité alors laissez-moi a commencé
par la présentation courte et vous dire
que je croyais il ya quelques temps que
nous étions dans la troisième révolution
de l'humanité la première étant
l'invention de l'écriture qui a permis
de stocker du savoir lorsque quelqu'un
connait c'est quelque chose avant
l'écriture ça disparaît c'est avec la
personne et tout à coup en écrivant on a
pu stocker et accumulé le savoir
première révolution
la deuxième révolution pour moi était
l'invention de l'imprimerie qui a permis
de multiplier ce savoir et de le
distribuer à l'ensemble de l'humanité et
la troisième révolution que je pensais
être celle dans laquelle nous aidons
nous sommes c'est internet
tout le savoir à la disposition de tout
le monde imaginez une recherche google
vous avez tous expérimentés vous poser
une question à google non seulement il
fini votre question avant que vous ayez
terminer la phrase vous dites mais
comment il savait il m'écoute ou quoi
mais en plus lorsqu'il vous donne en
millions de réponses en général la
réponse à votre question est dans la
première ou la deuxième ligne tout le
savoir de l'humanité au bout de nos
doigts
voilà dans quel monde nous sommes et
aujourd'hui avec le cognitives computing
c'est à dire la capacité de machines
d'imiter le raisonnement humain est ce
qu'on n'est pas rentré aujourd'hui dans
la quatrième révolution de l'humanité
est d'avoir des machines qui en ayant
accès à tout ce savoir
mais en appliquant le raisonnement
humain peut être encore plus rapidement
clou nous permettrait de faire des autos
découverte
et de faire progresser l'humanité et de
la porter au delà de ses limites
voilà pour ma première présentation
alors si vous voulez bien je vais
commencer la seconde la plus longue et
vous parlez du cognitives computer
qu'est ce que c'est le cognitif
computing à 2mo cognitives avait
comploté leur camping en général on sait
bien ce que c'est c'est des ordinateurs
qui utilisent des programmes qui
manipulent des données pour nous donner
une fonctionnalité que l'on souhaite le
cognitives
c'est le domaine du city chic du
raisonnement de d'apprendre quelque
chose l'apprentissage ont pensé pendant
un certain temps que ce domaine était
réservée aux êtres vivants aux humains
et puis il ya quelques temps on a
commencé à avoir des doutes et je sais
pas si vous aimez les échecs moi j'aime
bien les échecs et pendant toute ma
jeunesse qui a eu lieu il ya quelques
temps je l'admets on m'a toujours répété
jamais une machine ne gagnera aux échecs
contre une personne parce que la
puissance de raisonnement qu'il faut
pour jouer aux échecs est telle que
seuls les trains sont capables de faire
ça et puis il ya vingt ans peut-être
vous vous souvenez le champion du monde
kasparov s'est fait battre par une
machine alors je vous avoue j'ai été
très déçu on peut exciter mais quand
même déçu pour mes hôtes a menti sur les
capacités du cerveau humain mais plus
proche de nous il y a eu le jeu jeopardy
aux états unis est la finale le jeu j'ai
au père lei pour ceux qui ne le
connaissent pas ces enjeux de
connaissance générale on vous pose des
questions vous retrouvez les réponses et
en général sur des questions très
générale et la finale a réuni trois
personnes entre guillemets puisqu'il
s'agissait de deux êtres humains est une
machine et la machine à gagner
une machine qui était capable de
comprendre les questions de les
interpréter de chercher dans sa base de
connaissance qui n'était pas connecté
les réponses est d'apporter la réponse
donc le doute n'était plus permis
aujourd'hui vous avez des médecins
oncologues qui utilisent des systèmes
pareil ils vous disent que s'ils veulent
s ils veulent s'ils veulent rester à
jour sur leurs connaissances ils doivent
lire à peu près 23 heures par jour on
comprend tout de suite leurs problèmes
et aujourd'hui des machines sont capable
d'ingurgiter toutes ses connaissances et
de re délivré aux médecins aux colloques
des raisonnements basées sur les
analyses du patient et l'oncologue
vérifie ses raisonnements et lui propose
éventuellement des modifications
donc voilà ce que c'est avec le cognitif
computing c'est dans le passé on a
inventé les machines pour remplacer nos
bras pour être plus forts pour faire les
choses de manière plus rapide plus
puissante
aujourd'hui le cognitif computing nous
propose des machines qui remplace nos
cerveaux et on parle d'intelligence
artificielle je préfère le terme
d'intelligence augmenté c'est à dire
c'est une augmentation des capacités
intellectuelles de notre raisonnement
pour penser plus vite et mieux
donc voilà le cognitif computing et on
sait aujourd'hui que les super computer
ont une puissance plus élevée que le
cerveau humain
on sait également que dans dix ans les
super computer auront la puissance de
calcul de tous les cerveaux de la
planète donc en mettant tout ça ensemble
on peut se demander si en fait ces
machines vont pas nous aider à découvrir
un certain nombre de choses
quelles sont les implications du code
natif computing je dirais que ses
implications sont majeurs vous savez que
lorsque quelqu'un fait de la recherche
on dit souvent que le découvreur n'est
pas propriétaire de sa découverte parce
qu'en fait c'était l'environnement qui a
permis cette découverte est en fait le
découvreur michael derniers centimètres
qui a permis de sortir cette cette
découverte
alors maintenant réfléchissons ensemble
fermons pas les yeux et imaginons de
prendre toute la connaissance de
l'humanité qu'on a accumulées jusqu'à
aujourd'hui qu'on fournit à une machine
et qui est capable de faire des
raisonnements plus rapide et plus
puissante les nôtres est ce que ces
machines ne serait pas capable de faire
tous ces derniers centimètres est de
générer des découvertes
vous savez le théorème de fermat qui est
si célèbre que les mathématiciens savent
juste mais n'arrive pas à démontrer
depuis 350 ans on peut très bien
imaginer aujourd'hui une machine puisse
démontrer le théorème de fermat ce qui
serait quand même au niveau d'une
industrie ou de domaines comme les
mathématiques en grand succès alors
qu'elle est la liaison avec cette
conférence cybersécurité et bien je
travaille dans le domaine de la sécurité
et certains disent aujourd'hui le
d'arcsight à gagner ils sont capables de
rentrer dans votre téléphone dans vos
vies dans vos informations de vous voler
vos informations personnelles votre
argent ils ont gagné ils sont si
puissants sea organisé qu' on ne peut
plus rien faire contre eux et bien
aujourd'hui en maintenant ce genre
d'outil cognitives computing au service
de la défense
peut-être qu'on pourra gagner la
deuxième manche imaginons par exemple
qu'on mette toutes les connaissances que
l'on n'a sur la cybercriminalité
criminalité toutes les attaques toutes
les capacités de défense toutes les
méthodes que l'on peut avoir est d'avoir
une machine qui au lieu de mettre des
heures ou des jours à analyser une
attaque 10 en quelques secondes
voilà ce qui se passe tu es sous attaque
ce type d' attaque c'est ce type de
hackers qui est en train de travailler
et il relaie ce type d'information
donc voilà le contenu cognitif computing
à mon avis est en train de nous montrer
son potentiel il ne l'a pas encore tout
montré
mais il a la capacité de faire rentrer
l'humanité dans cette quatrième
révolution qui lui permettra peut-être
d'aller au delà de ses limites
[Applaudissements]